in this lesson we're going to talk about
arithmetic sequences in series so what's
an arithmetic sequence and what's an
arithmetic series well sequence just
means that it's a list and what makes it
arithmetic is that you're adding the
same thing each time to get to the next
term the next term the next term or and
then a series is basically a sum it
means that you're adding up all those
terms in that arithmetic list that
arithmetic sequence so a couple formulas
that are good to
know and memorize are the formula that
allows you to find the nth term and what
this tells you is that a sub n is the
value of the nth term and it equals the
first term which is a sub 1 so 1 just
means the value of the first term
plus d which is the common difference
that's what you're adding or subtracting
to get to the next term and then times
the quantity n minus 1 and n just refers
to whatever term that you want to find
if it's a 100th term then n would be 100
a sub 100 would be the value of that
100th term and then this formula here
which is the the sum of n terms
uh which means if you're just you know
adding up you know n terms you would
take the number of terms n so if there's
20 terms it would be 20 divided by 2 and
then you take the quantity the first
term up you know plus the last term so
that quantity added together multiplied
by n over two so let's go through a
couple examples go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do these on your
own i hope that this is a familiar to
you from your algebra 2 class
but if not we can review it here so
they're giving us the sequence this list
here it's five seven nine eleven
thirteen dot dot dot and so on and it's
like a two part question
one it says find the twentieth term okay
and then part two says you know find the
sum of the first twenty terms
well
go ahead and see if you can do this on
your own we'll do it together but
there's not that many terms 20 terms if
you wanted to you could just keep you
can see they're adding two each time you
could just keep adding two adding two
adding two you could write those out
it's not that many you could then you
know go ahead and find that 20th term
and then the sum you could then go ahead
and you know add all of them up so it
wouldn't be that bad to write them out
it's just this concept of understanding
that you know this pattern continues you
keep adding two that's the common
difference here but if it was a hundred
terms you know that might take up a
little bit too much time and that's
where the formulas really come in you
know and come in handy but let's just
get right into this so basically if we
want to find the value of the 20th term
i'm using this formula up here we're
taking the first term which is five okay
plus the common difference which is two
we keep adding two each time now if it
was subtracting 2 i'd make this a
negative 2 and then the
number of terms the term that i want i
mean the nth term is 20. so this would
be
5 plus 2 times 19
okay which is 38 plus 5 which is 43 so
the value of that 20th term is going to
be 43.
now part b here says you know find the
sum of the first 20 terms again we could
write them out and add them up
but we can also use this formula here
we're trying to find the sum of the
first 20 terms would be 20 over 2
the first term is 5 that's what the a
sub 1 represents and then the last term
okay a sub n
is the 20th term which is 43. so if we
add those together we get 48
20 divided by 2 is 10 and 10 times 48 is
480 so that would be the sum of the
first 20 terms so definitely something
important to understand more than one
way to go about it especially if there's
not that many terms like i said you can
list them out
that wouldn't take that long if there's
only a few but if there's more than this
is where these forms can really come in
handy so again something to review i'll
see you in the next lesson